uma revolução silenciosa acontece hoje
em diversas cidades ao redor do mundo
em nome dessa revolução é do prato ao
prato fechar o ciclo do prato ao prato é
transformar o próprio lixo em comida
a compostagem dos resíduos orgânicos
geram adubo de alta qualidade excelente
para ser usado em hortas urbanas com 75%
da população do planeta morando em
cidades a destinação correta do lixo que
a gente gera é tarefa fundamental para a
gente recuperar a saúde do planeta e de
todos nós a situação cada brasileiro
produz por dia um quilo de resíduo
orgânico por dia
são 200 milhões de quilos gerados todos
os dias no brasil
aqui a gente já tem uma lei federal a
política nacional de resíduos sólidos
que está em vigor desde agosto do ano
passado 2014
infelizmente essa essa lei ainda não foi
colocada em prática por falta de opções
no mercado incipiente que por enquanto
só oferece como solução os aterros
sanitários e os lixões mas o fato é que
a gente não precisa ficar esperando a
criação de políticas públicas e muito
menos se conformar com essa situação
triste
a compostagem pode começar dentro de
casa e por enquanto a melhor solução são
os minhocários é bem mais simples do que
parece manter minha cara em casa muita
pouca gente sabe mas até quem mora num
num apartamento de 30 metros quadrados
pode manter o minhocário e começar
reciclar o lixo da sua cozinha
eu na própria internet a gente encontra
vários tutoriais ensinando a montar o
seu próprio como esse
ensinando a montar o seu próprio nem o
caro inclusive a partir de materiais
reciclados como caixas e baldes tão
baixo custo
vivo pra todo mundo eu os anos atrás eu
encomendei um pela internet
e aí chegou em casa na caixinha fechada
pelo correio
o marido foi correndo toda animada é
abrir a caixa que ele achou que tinha
chegado os livros que tinha comprado
pela internet a ele abra a caixa tem 250
mil focas californiano
ele sai correndo com medo das minhocas
mas eu posso garantir a vocês que as
minhocas tem um eficiente elas são muito
organizadas são muito eficientes e elas
são muito mais limpinhos do que a gente
é incrível que o meu caro pode
transformar a vida de uma família
recentemente a prefeitura de são paulo
onde eu moro distribuiu minhocários para
duas mil famílias de todas as classes
sociais e os resultados das primeiras
pesquisas mostram que 78% dos
participantes mudaram seus hábitos
alimentares começaram a consumir mais
frutas e verduras além disso começar a
plantar aumentou o pessoal começou na
laje começou a colocar plantas porque
eles tinham que dar uma destinação
correta ao tubo que lhe estavam
produzindo e por fim um terço dessas
pessoas contou que acabou ensinando pra
vizinhos amigos familiares a montar o
seu próprio minhocário
então às vezes muitas vezes até sem
saber eles foram formando uma rede de
pessoas capazes de transformar a
realidade ao seu redor
e foi isso que aconteceu com os
hortelões urbanos
os hotéis urbanos são as pessoas que
gostam de manter a horta quem mora na
cidade mas quer ter uma hortinha nem que
seja no apartamento e essas pessoas
antes estavam isoladas nas suas casas
fazendo a sua tinha e as redes sociais
favorecer com que elas se encontrassem e
rapidamente os hortelões começaram eu
inclusive a trocar dicas de cultivo e
depende de começou a organizar os
piqueniques para trocar mudas e sementes
e disso para as hortas comunitárias foi
um pulo
a gente começou a época de
ações como essa a gente está vendo aqui
é essa é uma horta que existe no meio da
avenida paulista
pouca gente sabe inclusive os
paulistanos que tem uma horta não é
muito grande já tem 30 metros quadrados
e ela fica curiosamente num no lugar
onde as manifestações se encontram pra
fsi se concentram pra reunião então é
uma uma horta muito emblemática 2011 a
gente tinha uma horta comunitária em são
paulo
hoje são mais de 40 kg está criando
quase uma horta por mês
e estas hortas acabaram virando espaços
de convívio de reocupação de fato da
cidade mas só haver muita troca
muitas vezes a gente não se conhece não
somos amigos no nos conhecemos mas nos
reconhecemos no desejo comum de mudar a
cidade de fazer uma cidade melhor
então começamos a organizar piqueniques
então tem alguém que comanda pela cidade
começa a colher as amoras o pitanga na
época de pitanga das árvores que estão
nas calçadas e faz uma geléia e durante
o mutirão na horta leva geléia para
compartilhar início a gente começou a
descobrir plantas comestíveis não
convencionais também fazendo aquele
matinho que cresce lá no meio da calçada
que ser um dá valor
ela não só esse matinho pode não ser só
muito rico nutricionalmente como tem uma
infinidade de receitas para fazer com
ele você não precisa pagar tão caro pra
pra comprar um alimento bom está mais
perto do que a gente pensa mais ao nosso
alcance
então o elenco que conseguiu uma mudinha
de capuchinha também levei ora pro nobis
e aí comecei com adubo em casa ficou
grande ficou bonito mas ainda não saber
como comer aquilo porque não tava na
minha dieta não aprendi com minha mãe é
comer capuchinha então a gente começou a
trocar e e pesquisar novas receitas
isso você começa a prestar mais atenção
no que você está comendo que eu tô do
que eu estou me alimentando né
bom isso tudo eu sou jornalista não é
comum apresentou mas eu queria fazer
mais
eu queria ampliar esse ciclo virtuoso
pra outros setores da sociedade e é bom
quem já teve a alegria o prazer de ir
pra são paulo sabe que além de carro e
poluição a gente tem uma uma cena
gastronômica muito rica
imagina a quantidade de lixo gerado
pelos restaurantes
eu falei puxa eu também tinha visto uma
palestra do yunus falei ok vou fazer o
meu negócio social também então decidir
fundar o instituto quando com o objetivo
de fazer a coleta seletiva dos resíduos
orgânicos gerados pelos restaurantes
transformar isso adubo e devolver em
forma de hortas pode ser a horta no
próprio restaurante ou pode ser junto
aos agricultores urbanos são paulo tem
mil famílias de agricultores urbanos têm
roça em são paulo
eles não são reconhecidos por lei não
tem política pública pra isso
então a gente também tem o objetivo de
fazer a ponte entre os produtores e os
restaurantes para que eles possam os
produtores cresceu a forma de produzir
alimento puro orgânico e os restaurantes
possam melhorar a cena gastronômica com
produtos de mais qualidade para oferecer
aos seus clientes
bom eu não tinha milhões para investir
não tinham planos de negócios e
obviamente não tinha um fundo de
investimento
então eu falei bom mas é tem que começar
eu comecei falei com 12 restaurantes que
já estavam sensibilizados com a causa e
comecei a levar o lixo no porta-malas
meu carro eu sou mãe dona de casa
então quando eu vi estava dirigindo
estava levando as crianças que o gato
cachorro eo lixo no porta-malas mãe pelo
amor de deus eu não quero andar sentar
com o lixo do carro bem o fedor é e
ninguém falou que ia ser fácil né
mas eu tinha um propósito
era mais do que um trabalho é um
propósito de vida
então encontrei um terreno sub utilizado
por uma fábrica em são paulo mesmo e
peguei meu irmão que também estava
trabalhando só trabalhar e falei 'vamos
lá' carregar lixo ea gente começou a
carregar 300 quilos de lixo e levar para
comportar nesse terreno
aos poucos a gente é emagrecer eu perdi
basta esquilo com forte cunho e olha é
bem melhor que a academia não é o que a
gente fala que é o agrofit nesse e bom
essa compostagem é um pouco diferente a
gente não usa minhoca são a enzimas
catalisadores para acelerar o processo
de compostagem até porque o lixo de
restaurantes é um nicho muito punk né a
gente recolhe ossos carcaça de peixe é
já abriu a cabeça de bode é é um lixo
bem difícil e eu precisava fazer
experimentos então comecei a levar um
pouco do composto que demora um pouco
para maturar
mas eu levava pra casa pra começar a
experimentar e com poço ele enquanto ele
numa atura ele vai soltando um cheirinho
não muito agradável
então eu já cheguei em casa tava família
os vizinhos todo procurando que persegue
um bicho morto por ali é onde é que está
esse bicho eu fiquei quietinha não é
verão
não sei de nada é a gente hoje tem um
ano e pouco de atividades
estamos com dez restaurantes parceiros
não é nada mau para um negócio
totalmente pioneiro maluco que eu ainda
não vi nenhum lugar do brasil nem do
mundo e já conseguimos fazer a ponte com
alguns produtores já estão conseguindo
vender os restaurantes e os chefes estão
fazendo cardápio de acordo com os
produtos que eles têm a oferecer e os
cozinheiros que achavam que antes
a ave estava meio receoso que não tem
mais trabalho trabalho na cozinha muito
puxado muito quente e eles a gente vai
ter que separar o lixo mas é assim em 15
dias eles percebem que a separação do
lixo na verdade é muito fácil muito
prática só começar e que até ajuda a
organizar a cozinha e aos poucos eles
foram vendo que eles podiam escolher um
produto fresco para usar na cozinha
porque não tem comparação você ir lá e
pegar um eu o cheiro a qualidade do
sabor que é o que eles sempre estão
buscando é o melhor sabor
esse é o jairo ele está colhendo mastros
que é uma planta também um matinho usado
nos pratos mexicanos é um chef trouxe
uma muda de de erva maria luiza do sítio
no interior de minas gerais ea gente
conseguiu multiplicar essas mudas e
agora ele já consegue desenvolver o
produto é pratos já servir pratos com é
com essas mudas
a faxineira lindinha ela colhe o o capim
santo e faz um suco para os funcionários
no meio da tarde isso é uma alegria
quando falta eles ficam pedindo atrás
mas é o menino da confeitaria lembra da
avó que veio do sertão que gosta de roça
pede uma mudinha leva pra casa pra vou
começar e avó fica toda animada por que
volta a ter contato com a terra
essa daqui a hilda ailda ganhando
manjericão pra colocar no molho de
tomate
a alegria da ioda i e ii e aí a gente
pensa que caiu da tem em comum com o
engenheiro de uma grande construtora com
o ambientalista para tentar salvar a
amazônia com a professora da escola
pública do interior do brasil que nos
unem invariavelmente é o prato de comida
somos todos diferentes mas somos
completamente interdependentes
o dia propor hoje aqui pra todo mundo
respirar fundo encarar o próprio lixo
porque a revolução que a gente tanto
quer
começa na cozinha e comer pode e deve
ser um ato político e viva as minhocas